y este es probablemente el vídeo que más
nos habéis pedido y al mismo tiempo tal
vez el más complejo de todos los que
hemos abordado tras 52 años de
enfrentamientos el conflicto entre las
fuerzas armadas revolucionarias de
colombia conocidas como las farc y el
gobierno colombiano ha llegado
virtualmente a su fin a las 00 horas del
pasado 29 de agosto de 2016 para quienes
no las conozcan las farc son una
guerrilla de corte marxista leninista
que desde su fundación hace ya más de
medio siglo han sembrado el terror por
toda colombia un invento maquiavélico
desgarro la vida de 119 personas 42 de
ellas niños un cilindro-bomba del grupo
terrorista de las farc buscaba impactar
a grupos paramilitares pero los
inocentes pagaron una afrenta hablamos
de la guerrilla más importante de un
país donde la mayoría de sus habitantes
nunca han conocido la paz precisamente
hace poco tuve la oportunidad de estar
en colombia y si algo me quedó claro es
que es muy difícil encontrar siquiera
una familia que no haya sido afectada
por este terrible escenario la herencia
de las farc y demás grupos guerrilleros
como él
el m-19 o las autodefensas unidas de
colombia ponen los pelos de punta a lo
largo de estos años se han producido
27.000 secuestros 25.000 personas
continúan aún desaparecidos y más de 220
mil colombianos han perdido la vida los
soldados se quedaron sin palabras cuando
comprobaron que uno de sus enemigos era
apenas un niño además cerca de 6
millones de personas fueron forzadas a
abandonar sus tierras y sus casas y a
todo ello hay que añadir claro el
continuo ataque a la infraestructura de
todo tipo de ductos puentes
ferrocarriles un horror vaya llegar a un
acuerdo no ha sido en absoluto una tarea
sencilla de hecho ya existieron dos
grandes intentos que fueron liderados
respectivamente por los presidentes
belisario betancur a mediados de los
años 80 y andrés pastrana en torno al
año 2000 fue precisamente a partir de
este segundo intento fallido cuando se
puso en marcha el llamado plan colombia
un acuerdo de colaboración con eeuu
impulsado por bill clinton por el cual
el 'tío sam' aportaba cada año ingentes
recursos para la lucha contra el
narcotráfico cuando conseguían una señal
no sabías a quién escuchaba
por eso entonces el gobierno
estadounidense desarrolló un programa
que podía identificar las voces de
nuestros objetivos y es que ojo las
diferentes guerrillas se convirtieron
con el paso del tiempo en poderosos
cárteles de la droga
así se estima que por ejemplo tan solo
las farc consiguen facturar cada año más
de 600 millones de dólares con los
narcóticos incluso después de haber
pagado sus guerrilleros las farc tenían
activos por valor de 10 mil 500 millones
de dólares en 2012 bien a pesar de lo
que podría parecernos el acuerdo de paz
está polarizando la sociedad colombiana
y el apoyo al mismo no es ni mucho menos
unánime para explicar esta paradójica
situación tenemos que analizar cómo se
ha desarrollado la negociación así pues
porque aceptaron las farc iniciar
conversaciones para alcanzar la paz en
primer lugar la doctrina para la
seguridad democrática y la estrategia de
mano dura puesta en marcha por el
anterior presidente álvaro uribe junto
al plan colombia de los eeuu le causaron
un daño importantísimo a las farc que
veían como día a día sus fuerzas eran
diezmadas de hecho en poco tiempo las
fuerzas de seguridad colombiana se
acabaron con la vida de importantes
dirigentes de la organización como fue
el caso por ejemplo de 'raúl reyes' mono
jojoy o alfonso cano
además el cada vez mayor uso de
tecnologías como los drones y los
seguimientos por satélite hacen hoy muy
difícil esconderse con lo que se puede
decir que la suerte está prácticamente
echada en segundo lugar el régimen
chavista demostró que era posible y más
efectivo hacerse con el poder mediante
estrategias políticas y por cierto si
algo tenían las farc eran dinero para
lograrlo
porque están en la selva corriendo el
riesgo de ser bombardeados si se puede
conquistar el poder desde cómodo
despacho además con el apoyo y el
asesoramiento de los amigos chavistas
cuál ha sido el papel del presidente
juan manuel santos pues lo cierto es que
el papel de santos ha sido muy
controvertido tanto que incluso apoyando
su iniciativa de impulsar las
negociaciones para la paz no me veo
capaz de defender bajo ninguna
perspectiva la estrategia que ha seguido
durante el proceso su incomprensión por
los problemas que comenzaba a padecer la
banda y su empeño por obtener un
histórico éxito político llevó las
negociaciones por unos derroteros
sorprendentes en primer lugar redujo la
presión del ejército y las fuerzas del
orden sobre los guerrilleros de tal
forma que claro según todas las
estimaciones disponibles el negocio de
la droga tanto a nivel de cultivo como
de producción y distribución ha
repuntado muchísimo los últimos años
fortaleciendo con ello la posición de
las farc la guerrilla de las farc
continúa vinculada al narcotráfico pese
a las negociaciones de paz con el
gobierno de colombia lo denuncia el jefe
de la policía antinarcóticos del país
segundo aceptó negociar sin que las farc
hubiesen suspendido siquiera sus
operaciones criminales de tal forma que
durante la negociación esta panda de
criminales acabó con la vida de más de
1.500 policías y militares negociar
amistosamente mientras esos salvajes
cometen semejante barbarie
es de locos tercero no fijó ningún plazo
límite para la negociación de tal forma
que lo que tenía que haber durado meses
duró años y es que esta posición era muy
cómoda para los jefes de la guerrilla
estaban cómodamente instalados en la
habana disfrutando del clima y los
encantos caribeños seguían haciendo
mucho dinero con sus actividades
delictivas
y encima podían reorganizarse por si
fuese poco la negociación era conocida y
además se desarrollaba en cuba bajo el
cobijo del régimen castrista lo que en
definitiva suponía más presión para el
gobierno colombiano no se puede olvidar
la importancia vital de este gesto
muerto para el arribo al feliz puerto
del acuerdo final es decir juan manuel
santos hizo todo lo contrario de lo que
se supone que hay que hacer en una
situación así y claro estas cosas luego
se notan en el resultado
por qué es tan controvertido este
acuerdo de paz en colombia'
pues básicamente lo es porque buena
parte del pueblo colombiano entiende que
los miembros de las farc han obtenido
demasiadas prebendas
es decir demasiadas confesiones hay
quien considera que incluso el gobierno
ha llegado a faltar al respeto a la
memoria de todas las víctimas cuando uno
pide perdón es porque se arrepintió
derecho algo yo no me estoy
arrepintiendo haber hecho lo que haya
hecho quizás quizás quizás el documento
final tiene casi 300 páginas con lo que
os podéis imaginar que únicamente
podremos destacar de una forma sintética
en las cuestiones más relevantes de
hecho la primera parte del acuerdo de
paz se centra en políticas agrícolas y
rurales tal cual el gobierno de colombia
ha consensuado un programa político con
el grupo terrorista un programa además
muy escorado a la izquierda que
contempla las zonas de reserva campesina
se han convertido en áreas del control
del terrorismo y que así lo que es peor
en el futuro no se podría modificar en
segundo lugar el acuerdo no exige
arrepentimiento y además contempla en la
práctica
por todos los crímenes incluidos los
delitos de sangre y narcotráfico en esta
línea para aquellos que confiesen
crímenes contra la humanidad no habrá
penas de cárcel sino penas alternativas
dictadas por un tribunal especial donde
la propia banda estará en cierto modo
representada tercero se contempla la
transformación de la guerrilla en un
partido político que tendrá ojos incluso
reservados cinco asientos en el senado y
cinco asientos en la cámara de
representantes que podrán ser elegidos a
dedo además de crearse 16 y
suscripciones especiales que por
supuesto estarán bajo control de la
banda si los colombianos aprueban el
acuerdo el peligro a largo plazo es que
la guerrilla exploten las concesiones
políticas para socavar la democracia
cuarto los líderes de las farc no
tendrán que pagar indemnización alguna
de las víctimas y podrán conservar
intactas la inmensa fortuna acumulada
mediante la extorsión y el narcotráfico
el estado pagará por ellos a las
víctimas quinto los más de siete mil
guerrilleros que forman la organización
recibirán importantes subsidios del
gobierno para facilitar su tránsito a la
vida civil así algunos cálculos estiman
en torno a los dos
75 millones de pesos unos 90 mil dólares
estadounidenses el dinero que le costará
a la hacienda pública cada guerrillero
así por todo ello no nos puede resultar
extraño que un acuerdo de paz llamado a
hacer historia sea tan polémico que
figuras tan relevantes como los
expresidentes álvaro uribe y andrés
pastrana se opongan fervientemente a
ellos y es que no resulta nada sencillo
por un lado esta loable deseo de
alcanzar la paz de una vez por todas por
otro lado evitar que quienes han causado
tanto dolor se acaben saliendo con la
suya y condicionen por décadas la
sociedad y la política colombiana
personalmente me encanta colombia sus
gentes sus paisajes su alegría
y espero de verdad que en poco tiempo
este bello país sería libre de la
violencia para siempre que penséis
nosotros es bueno el acuerdo de paz ha
conseguido juan manuel santos- el
acuerdo que colombia merece seguiremos
de cerca todas las novedades y muy
pronto hablaremos más de colombia entre
otras cosas comentaremos el cambio de
tendencia económica que está registrando
el país para seguirlo con nosotros no te
olvides de suscribirte al canal por
cierto el pasado viernes os dejamos un
mensaje en nuestras cuentas de facebook
y twitter como a un 6 muchos los que no
nos seguís por ahí aprovecho para
invitaros a verlos y de paso seguirnos
en ambas redes donde iremos compartiendo
nuevos materiales diferentes a los de
youtube un saludo y hasta la próxima
acaso
sí
no no no